wherever Narendra Modi goes controversy
usually follows outside the Houston
Stadium in advance of the indian prime
minister speech Modi supporters
physically grabbed Al Jazeera's camera
and yanked press credentials as we tried
to film those protesting his visit Modi
was once banned for years for entering
the United States for violations of
religious freedom but on Sunday he stood
in front of thousands of Indian
Americans alongside US President Donald
Trump Howard a my friends the massive
rally is designed to beam a positive
image of Modi after international
criticism of his move stripping Kashmir
of its autonomy there's also been a
surge of attacks under Modi's government
against religious minorities in India
analysts say Modi's nationalist brand of
politics is very similar to Trump's
ideologically they're surprisingly
similar they are invested in the kind of
nationalism or kind of muscular
nationalism kind of strong nationalism
and they kind of speak in the same idiom
but on stage the pair touted the
economic benefits of the friendship the
American economy strong our two nations
have taken their relationship to new
heights you enrich your culture you
uphold our values you uplift our
communities and you are truly proud to
be American Trump and Modi hope to sign
a trade deal during Modi's visit to
boost India's sluggish economy it would
also give Trump an economic win after a
prolonged US trade war with China but
outside the rally many people protested
the joint appearance of the two leaders
this woman says she's furious Trump
granted Modi the global legitimacy he
seeks number one he has divided his
country number two
he has he had a things at Amos tedran
that has been going on in push meat
producer motors does not in general
[Music]
Kimberly Hellcat al-jazeera Houston
Texas